Picture this. You're scrolling through your feed on a Tuesday morning and you see a headline. It says, drinking three cups of coffee a day is associated with living longer.
Oh, I see those all the time.
Right. Now, be completely honest with yourself. When you read that, do you instantly think, oh, great, coffee causes a longer life. I should probably start drinking more.
I mean, yeah, most of us make that leap instantly. We see two things happening together and our brains just, you know, immediately construct a story connecting them.
Exactly. Coffee equals a longer life.
Yeah, we want the world to have clear rules.
But in the world of science, we are constantly beaten over the head with the golden rule, right? Correlation does not imply causation.
Right. Just because two things happen at the same time doesn't mean one caused the other.
Exactly. Yet when we read about a new study, we almost always make that leap anyway. And today we are going to look at why that happens. And more shockingly, who is actually encouraging us to make that leap?
Because it turns out we can't just blame the media or casual readers for misunderstanding the science.
No, we can't.
A massive amount of the time, it is the scientists themselves baiting the hook.
Yeah. And that brings us to what we're doing today. Today's deep dive is unpacking this monumental new paper. It was published in Nature Human Behavior on August 24th, 2026. I knew. Super recent. It's by Calvin Ish, Timothy
Doerr, Neil Fashing, Grace Jennings, and Duncan J. Watts out of the University of Pennsylvania. And our mission today is to explore a phenomenon they call narrative license.
narrative license. I love that term. It's
so good. We are looking at how social scientists frequently use language that wildly overreaches their actual statistical proof and how artificial intelligence is simultaneously highlighting this problem and in many ways actively making it worse.
Yeah, and to really ground this, we are stacking this new paper with four background studies. Because we need to understand the underlying psychology of, well, why humans fall for this. Right. And the systemic pressures that force scientists to do it. Plus, the cutting-edge AI methods required to
even measure a problem of this scale.
Okay, let's unpack this. Before we can judge the impact of scientists exaggerating their claims, we have to understand the sheer scale of the problem.
Which is massive.
It really is. And to do that, we have to define what a cross-sectional study actually is.
Right, so a cross-sectional study is essentially a photograph.
Okay.
You were looking at data from a single point in time across a specific population. Because you aren't tracking variables over time like a video or running a controlled experiment where you manipulate a variable, you could only show an association.
You can just prove that two things are happening simultaneously.
Exactly. By definition, the design cannot establish causation. You absolutely cannot say X made Y happen.
Yet when the authors of this new paper analyzed nearly 200,000 cross-sectional articles, they found something deeply alarming.
Yeah, the numbers are wild.
Across 194,631 cross-sectional articles, 46.3% use causal language in the title or the abstract.
Almost half.
Almost half. And the historical trend is what really gets me here. From 1980 to the year 2000, that number hovered around 20%.
Which is still a lot, but, you know, somewhat stable.
Right. But then it skyrocketed. It rose almost threefold to over 60% by 2024.
Which means that right now, if you are reading a cross-sectional social science paper, it is more likely than not that the authors are claiming a causal relationship their data simply cannot prove.
Which is, I mean, is this basically the academic version of clickbait?
Honestly, yes. It's dressing up an association to sound like a hard fact.
Okay, but I'm stuck on the logistics here. How on earth does a human research team read almost 200,000 dense academic papers without spending 30 years doing it?
Well, they didn't. They had to use a very modern three-step human-in-the-loop workflow inside a platform called ProQuest's TDM Studio.
TDM Studio.
Yeah, it's what's known as a walled garden environment. Publishers keep their data strictly locked down, right? So you can't just scrape the internet for them.
Oh, because of copyrights and all that.
Exactly. So first, they ran a massive keyword search within that walled garden, which returned 321,322 candidate studies.
Still way too many for a human to read.
Way too many. So step two, they took a small sample, just 200 abstracts, and had human experts code them.
OK, humans doing the baseline work.
Right. And they use those to validate a prompt for GPT-4-0, asking the AI to classify if a study was truly cross-sectional. Once that was validated, they unleashed GPT-4-0 on 30,000 abstracts.
Wait, if GPT-4 is so smart, why didn't they just have it read all 300,000 papers? Why stop at 30,000?
Economics and scale, mostly. Running massive, large language models on hundreds of thousands of academic texts gets incredibly expensive. And computationally heavy.
Ah, right. It burns through tokens.
Exactly. Yeah. So they distilled the knowledge GPT-4 generated into a fine-tuned BERT classifier.
Okay, BERT.
Yeah, BERT is an older, lighter, more specialized AI model that is exceptionally good at text classification. They trained BERT on the 30,000 GPT-labeled abstracts and then validated it on another 10,000.
Did it actually work, though? I mean, going from human to GPT to BERT feels like a game of telephone.
It did work. It achieved an F1 score of 0.92 and an overall accuracy of 0.91.
Let's break down that F1 score for a second, because we see that term thrown around a lot in AI. And I think people get confused if accuracy is just, you know, how many did you get right? What is F1 measuring?
Think of it like a brutal exam that tests two things at once. It tests your ability to find all the needles in a haystack. That's recall.
Okay, recall.
But it also tests your ability to not accidentally pick up pieces of hay and call them needles. That's precision.
Oh, that makes sense.
So an F1 score of .92 means BERT was incredibly good at finding the cross-sectional studies without getting confused by false positives. And once they had that dialed in, they used a parallel BERT classifier to hunt for the causal language itself.
And we have a background paper from Fabrizio Gilardi and colleagues in 2023 that really puts this into perspective.
The annotation paper.
Yeah. Gilardi proved that ChatGPT could beat human crowd workers on text annotation tasks by about 25 points. But the kicker is the cost. It did it for under a third of a cent per annotation.
Which is just, that economic shift is profound. Analyzing 194,631 articles wasn't just computationally possible, it was dirt cheap. But we have to call out the elephant in the room here.
The reflexivity paradox.
Yes.
The irony is almost too much to handle. The authors are using large language models as the very instrument to measure a problem exaggerated scientific claims that LLMs actually make much worse, which we will definitely get into later.
It's a fascinating loop, using the disease to diagnose the disease. But let's look at the data they extracted. Who are the worst offenders when it comes to overreaching?
The disciplinary breakdown is wild.
Yeah.
Business is the absolute highest. A staggering 84% of cross-sectional business papers use causal language.
Wow. 84%. Yeah.
Then economics at 67%, psychology at 55%, political science at 53%, and sociology is the lowest at 46%. I mean,
that makes total sense if you think about the audience for those papers. Well, an executive or a policymaker reading a business or economics paper... doesn't want to hear, oh, these two factors interestingly co-occur. They want to know, what lever do I pull to make
my profit margin go up?
They want actionable results, even if the math doesn't actually support the action.
Exactly.
And here's where it gets really interesting. You might assume this is a problem with lower tier, maybe predatory journals that don't have rigorous peer review.
That would be the logical guess, yeah. But
the Ish paper found the exact opposite. Higher impact journals are actually more likely to overreach. Really? Yeah. In journals with an impact factor above 3.03, causal language sits at 54.4%. For journals below
the median impact factor, it drops to 43.3%.
So the more prestigious the journal, the more likely the authors are to claim causation.
Yep. They even looked at a very specific journal, the Journal of Quantitative Description, Digital Media. Okay. This journal explicitly bans causal claims in its submissions. They practically have a giant neon sign on their submission page saying, no causation allowed.
And yet the researchers still found a 12.9% rate of causal language. It's like a vegan restaurant getting caught serving bacon in 13% of its dishes.
That is hilarious, but also terrible. It shows how deeply ingrained this habit is. And if you think the abstracts are bad, wait until you look at the full texts.
Oh, right. The BERT classifier ran on the full text, too.
Yeah. When the researchers unleashed their AI on the bodies of these articles, they found that 81.8% of the articles contained at least one unhedged causal snippet somewhere in the paper.
Even when the authors were on their best behavior in the abstract, let's say you read an abstract that is purely descriptive, incredibly careful, no big claims. If you read the full text, 44% of the time there is an unhedged, direct, causal claim buried in there.
Just hiding in the paragraphs.
Yeah, and if the abstract used implied or conditional language-like, this might lead to never 72% of the time they drop the act in the full text and just go full causal.
And if we map out where these claims hide, a very clear pattern emerges. These unhedged claims cluster heavily in the introduction, 60% of the time, and the discussion section, 55.1% of the time.
But in the methods section.
Only 6.1%.
It's like they're strict accountants when they are doing the math in the methods section, but they turn into marketing executives the second they get to the discussion section. That
is exactly what's fascinating here. They know the rules. They just choose to break them to sell the narrative.
Which brings us to a vital question. Does this narrative license actually work? Like, does it fool anyone?
Right. Because if no one believes it, it doesn't matter. But to find out, the researchers ran a pre-registered experiment on human readers.
Yeah, they recruited 11,105 U.S. adults on a platform called Prolific. And crucially, all of them had at least a bachelor's degree. So we are talking about an educated audience. Highly
educated.
They gave them one of 28 abstracts from elite journals to read under four different conditions.
So Condition 1 was the original abstract, causal language intact. Condition 2, a rewritten version, scrubbed completely clean into strict dissociational language.
No causal claims at all.
Right. Condition 3 was the original abstract, but with a warning note about the methodological limits. And Condition 4 was the warning note, plus an AI feedback label literally highlighting the overreach in the text.
And the interventions did work to a degree, but we really need to look at the numbers here. They measured the drop in belief using a beta coefficient.
Okay, think of the beta coefficient like a volume dial on a stereo. A beta of zero means the intervention had no effect on the reader's belief. A negative beta means it turned the volume down on their belief that the study proved causation.
So the methodological label had a beta of metasor 0.4 and the associational rewrites had a beta of netasor 0.3.
Okay, so scrubbing language or adding a warning label did turn the dial down. People were more skeptical.
They were, but here's the core insight, the part that genuinely blew my mind, the residue. The
causal residue.
Yes. Even when causal claims were explicitly denied or entirely absent, readers kept inferring them.
Because the researchers asked the participants to write their own summaries of the papers they just read.
Right. And for the original abstracts, people used causal language 71.3% of the time. But for the rewritten, perfectly cautious, totally scrubbed versions, the readers still injected causal language 49.6% of the
time.
Almost half the time.
Half the time, the reader read a careful paper and summarized it with a causal claim that wasn't even there.
And this is where we bring in Samuel Gershman and Tomer Ullman's 2023 background paper on causal implicatures.
Oh, this paper is so important for this.
It really is. They proved experimentally that humans naturally infer causation from correlational statements. Even if you just write, X is associated with an increased risk of Y, people read that as X causes Y.
You know what's crazy about this? It makes me wonder if we literally can't help it. Like, if I read two facts side by side, my brain instantly tries to connect them with a because.
Are we just biologically hardwired to reject coincidence?
Maybe, because a purely statistical association doesn't give us a tool to survive or act on the world, but a cause-and-effect relationship does.
We are narrative creatures. Our cognitive default is to see causal models of the world, and this is the tension the scientists are exploiting.
Okay, but let's follow the logic here. If humans are fundamentally flawed readers who inject causation because we want a story, what happens when we outsource the reading to a machine?
Ah, yes.
The whole promise of AI is that it's cold, calculating, and immune to human bias. So if we hand these same papers to ChatGPT... It should strip out the emotion and give us the cold, hard, correlational math.
That's what you would think. But the machine experiments in this paper are terrifying. This is where the deep dive turns into a story about AI escalation.
Let's hear it.
First, they tested GPT-4.1 on those exact same abstracts. When summarizing the original abstracts, GPT-4.1 used causal language an astonishing 99.3% of the time. 99.3%. It completely failed to be the cold
calculating machine.
Completely. And even with the rewritten perfectly cautious abstract, GPT 4.1 summary was causal 89.8% of the time.
It's like the AI is forcing a story even harder than the humans did.
Exactly. It took the methodological warning note to drop it to 41.7% and the explicit AI feedback warning to get it down to 30.3%.
So they wanted to see if this was just a quirk of one model, so they ran a grand prompt experiment.
Right. They tested five different models, GPT-4.1, GPT-5.1, GPT-5.4, DeepSeqChat v3.2, and Anthropix CloudSonic 4.6.
A really good mix of the big players.
And they used 100 stratified articles and hit them with four different prompts, basic, simplifying, practical, and careful.
So the simplifying prompt asked for an eighth grade reading level. The practical prompt asked for real world significance. Right. Let's trace the flow of misinformation here because the numbers make it incredibly real. Out of 500 total summaries, the abstracts were originally labeled like this.
210 were strictly non-causal, 120 were conditional, and 170 were causal.
Okay, so we start with the 210 non-causal papers.
Under a basic summary prompt, the AI turned those into 250 causal summaries.
It just invented causation.
Yes. And under the simplified eighth grade prompt, 277 summaries became causal. Under the practical prompt, 294 became causal.
So the AI is literally taking nuanced science and flattening it into clickbait to make it sound useful or simple.
Think about how you use AI at work. If you drop a dense PDF into Claude or ChatGPT and say, hey, give me the practical takeaways for my team so I can sound smart in this meeting, this data shows the AI is actively inventing a cause and effect relationship just to
please you.
Which is terrifying, and this raises a massive point of tension in the field right now. Yeah. We have a background paper by Peters and Chin-Yi from 2025.
The model progression one.
Right. They tested 10 models on 4,900 summaries, and they found that newer models actually overgeneralize more.
Yeah.
They found LLM summaries were nearly five times more likely to contain broad generalizations than human-written ones.
So the smarter the model gets, the worse it gets at nuance.
That is the argument. However, in this new Ish paper, they found a contradiction. They noted that GPT-5.4 actually stopped showing the severe over-claiming pattern that GPT-4.1 did under a basic prompt.
Okay, so which is it? Is model progress inherently fixing this problem, as Ish found with GPT-5.4? Or is the safety entirely dependent on the specific model architecture and the exact prompt you use, meaning newer models could
still be wildly unsafe, as Peter suggests?
We honestly cannot resolve that tension today.
Oh, we can't.
We have to invite you, the listener, to just sit with that contradiction. We are in a transitional moment where we don't fully understand if the technology is naturally correcting itself or if we are just playing a game of whack-a-mole with different prompts and different updates.
But it brings us back to the systemic why. Both humans and AI are eager to strip out the hedges, the mites, and maybes. But why do the scientists initiate this chain reaction? Why write overreaching claims in the first place? It's not because they are, you know,
mustache-twirling villains trying to trick the public.
No, it's rarely conscious cheating. To understand this, we look at Paul Smaldino and Richard McGillreath's 2016 formal model of the natural selection of bad science.
Natural selection of bad science.
Yeah. It explains that threefold rise in over-claiming since the year 2000, better than any individual bad actor story could.
Because if you think about the institutional incentives hiring committees, promotion boards, and grant funders, they all emphasize one thing above all else, right? Impact.
You need publications. And journals select for novelty and importance.
So over time, these systemic pressures naturally select for bad methods and overreaching language. The scientists who hedge their bets and write incredibly cautious dry papers don't get the cover of nature.
No, they don't get 10 years fast either. The ones who write the bold causal claims do. It's an evolutionary pressure.
And if we map that out, we see what Tal Yarkoni called the generalizability crisis in his 2022 paper.
Right. He points out that there is a massive unacknowledged gap between the strict statistical models researchers use and the sweeping verbal hypotheses they write.
The math might prove that in a very specific lab setting with 50 undergrads, variable A moves slightly when variable B moved. But the verbal conclusion in the discussion section claims they have uncovered a fundamental truth about human psychology.
It's like a car manufacturer testing a vehicle's brakes at 10 miles an hour in an empty parking lot. That's the strict math. But then putting up a billboard claiming the car can safely stop on a dime during a hurricane.
The math doesn't match the marketing at all. But, I mean, should we just force every scientist to write like a robot, completely devoid of all narrative? Well,
Ish and his team are actually very careful to balance the argument here. Over-claiming isn't always a disaster. Sometimes it accelerates scientific progress by prompting fierce debate and rapid follow-up studies.
They mentioned Ronald Fisher, the famous statistician, right?
Yes. Fisher was notoriously skeptical about the link between smoking and cancer. Right. Why? Because the evidence was observational. It was cross-sectional and correlational. Technically, his skepticism was rooted in solid methodology.
But obviously, practically, waiting for a randomized controlled trial on smoking would have been a public health disaster.
Exactly. Sometimes you have to make the leap based on association.
And beyond that, the authors argue that eliminating narrative entirely would be counterproductive. Humans are storytelling creatures. We need a narrative to understand and retain information.
It's a tightrope walk. You need the story to make people care. But if the story strays too far from the mass, you're just writing fiction.
Which brings us to the ultimate paradox of this entire deep dive, the artificial intelligence paradox.
The very same technology, the large language models, that eagerly strips the hedges out of scientific text, flattening nuance into clickbait, is the exact tool the authors propose using to flag and fix this overreach at scale.
And it all comes down to the power of the prompt. Just remind yourself of that final data point from the machine experiments. When Isha's team used a careful prompt, one that explicitly asked the AI to focus on methodological limitations... the causal overreach rate plummeted.
It dropped down to just 75 causal summaries out of 500.
It cut the overreach down to roughly 5%.
A single sentence in a prompt completely changed how the machine translated the truth, which leaves us with a provocative thought to mull over.
Let's hear it.
We live in a world of information overload. More and more people are consuming research, not by reading the methodology of a 30-page PDF, but by asking an AI to summarize it for them. If so much of the credibility of global
scientific literature now rides on a single AI prompt, what happens as more readers meet research through an automated summary they didn't explicitly ask to be careful? When you read an AI-generated brief for a meeting, who decides what nuance gets
stripped away?
When you ask for the simple answer, the AI is more than happy to give you a definitive cause and effect, even if the science doesn't back it up. You might think you're getting the cold, hard facts, but you're just getting a story perfectly tailored to what your brain naturally wants to hear. Thank you so much for joining us on this deep dive.
Keep questioning the narratives you read, and the next time you see a headline about coffee, maybe remember the parking lot and the hurricane.